Let's go next to Ernest from Missouri. Ernest,
welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I wanted to kind of preface
my question by saying I love the way you engage
with all whose you don't necessarily agree with.
That's a skill I think, that's lost in the modern
political debate, or at least is slipping
away from us. Well, thank you for something.
Oh, you're welcome. What are your what are some
things you think we can do to, like, encourage
people to engage in more civil debates and kind
of to broaden that out a get away from like the
talking points and more on the issues at hand.
Speaker 1: You know, my view on this shifts
over time. One of the things I've been trying
recently is kind of putting it out there and
people who have seen my appearances on some
places recently, like the Michael Knowles Show
in Trigonometry might have noticed that I did,
as I say, up front, hey, do are we on the same
page that we want to have a good faith debate?
And we're not trying to do gotchas, but we're
trying to really solve problems or find shared
understanding, even if the other person doesn't
have any plan to do that. Usually they'll at least
say that that's their goal. And then you can use
that as something to point back to and say, hey,
listen, let's let's skip the talking points. We
both said we wanted a good faith conversation and
we want to try to find some answers. Can't we just
agree that X and it's sort of a cheap rhetorical
tool, but it might actually predispose people to
maybe come in with a slightly better attitude. You
know, if you asked me a year ago, I might have had
some different technique that I was trying
at the time. Another tool that can be useful
is starting with where we agree. So, you know,
you could have a very contentious issue like,
I don't know, abortion or something like
that. But you could first start with, well,
what what do we agree on? We we agree that murder
is bad. Certainly on all the instances where we
agree as to what murder is, we agree that we want
people's ability to determine the best course for
their life is something that should be priorities
that, you know, you lay out all of these areas of
agreement and this can often kind of really narrow
the scope of the disagreement in a way that it
seems more manageable. So that's another idea. But
this is a really big topic. And if you ask me in
six months, I might have a different perspective.
Speaker 2: Right. And so if you don't mind,
I kind of had a follow up. Yeah, please. Which
is what I think is the more relevant thing. And I
kind of wanted to frame that because you do do an
excellent job of, like, laying that out. Hmm. So
how do we. How do we use this to engage with,
like, these institutions that control us and
create tautology that we can kind of break down
and see are just objectively false, but yet they
stick to them and then even, you know, utilize
other legal means and like means of power
to to keep them to keep kind of these these
things true. Like, I'll use that in quotes.
Speaker 1: I see that as a really different
question. That's less about convincing any
individual with the tools I mentioned, that's
really more about how can just the people
get substantive access to those institutions where
often the access is reserved for corporations and
high powered donors. So that's a more systemic
question to me than one about what are like the
rhetorical tools that might be used.
Speaker 2: Okay. All right. Well,
thank you very much. I appreciate it. I think
that's the truth. The way truth is framed,
I think, is one of the most important things.
Mm hmm. One of the most important discussions
today. And so that's why I wanted to hit on that.
And thank you so much for answering my question.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. It was a great
question and a very, very important topic.